okay let's bring you some breaking news
that's coming out of Thailand the
Constitutional Court there has ordered a
temporary suspension of a leading Prime
ministerial candidate as an MP Peter
Linda ronrad had won the most number of
seeds in May's general elections we can
go to Florence Louis he was at the
parliament in Bangkok where MPS are
meeting for a second vote on his
Premiership this breaking news just
coming to us in the last 10 minutes or
so Florence talk us through what exactly
this temporary suspension could mean
foreign
suspension of Peter Lim Jaron as a
member of parliament doesn't affect his
nomination as prime minister candidate
it just means he's temporarily suspended
and this is in relation to a complaint
that the Constitutional court has
accepted that Peter may have broken
Thailand's election laws by holding
shares in a media company now Peter says
that company hasn't been operating
Broadcast News for at least 10 years and
that he was merely an executor of the
family's inherited shares done
separately in Parliament the members of
parliament legislators the
representatives and senators are
expected to vote for a second time on
Peter as prime minister but before that
there is a debate happening in
Parliament on whether he can be
re-nominated as a prime ministerial
candidate and that's because there is a
parliamentary regulation that says that
a motion that has already been tabled in
Parliament cannot be reintroduced within
the same session and there was already a
first vote for Peter as prime minister
that took place last week now if the if
he is nominee the votes will take place
but if he doesn't get enough votes then
his party will allow a second party that
is per tie with the second largest
number of votes in May's general
election to nominate a candidate now
that vote will likely happen on Thursday
and Florence give us a little bit more
background uh to Peter Linda ronrad
because he he his win was a little bit
of a surprise wasn't it they weren't
expecting that his party would do so
well
[Music]
that's right now progress move forward
party really it
it won the elections on a very you know
on on the promise of bringing reforms it
wanted to bring sweeping reforms to not
just the political system but also the
military and also the economy it wanted
to dismantle monopolies that control
very many of Thailand's most profitable
Industries now Peter Lim Jaron Rod is a
businessman and his party moved forward
is seen as a predecessor party of future
forward also another very Progressive
Party now there are a few scenarios that
could play out petalum General could win
the election he could be elected as
prime minister although that is very
unlikely now the likely the more likely
scenarios is that another name will be
nominated this will be a name from her
Thai party the second largest party in
Parliament however having said that that
party will also face the same obstacles
as move forward and that is because the
conservative establishment really do not
want to see move forward as part of
government because of what it stands for
and that is sweeping reforms they want
to protect the status quo so many
analysts have said that could take a
more pragmatic option and that is drop
move forward from any possible Alliance
moving forward now if that were to
happen we expect to see backlash in the
form of Street protests now Peter could
also be banned from politics by the
Constitutional court that could be
sometime in the future but that is what
happened to move forwards predecessor
party's leader Hanan
um and that saw widespread Street
protests in 2020. now if that were to
happen we could possibly see the
military getting more involved again in
the form of perhaps cracking down on
protesters possibly even declaring
martial law and that could mean
prolonged instability for Thailand Okay
thank you for that Florence Louis there
for us in Kuala Lumpur